[Applaudissements]
l'inspecteur derrick
ah bah oui bien sûr vous reconnaissez
l'inspecteur des verrines et des riders
socialement attention non mais en plus
ils malheureusement voilà enfin un peu
décédé actuellement il est il a passé
l'armé à gauche comme on dit dans le
milieu
voilà et bien d'eric alors il faut ça en
syrie lafayette le président de france
télévisions le président de plus belle
la vie janicot plus belle la vie tout le
chantier
je vous explique c'est qu'on avait fait
une version de derrick qui ressemble un
peu plus à cyril hanouna un derrick
vraiment du sud de l'allemagne
et on suit ses aventures toutes les
semaines avec le bourgueil son acolyte
j'ai cette semaine c'est derrick va
draguer tranquille avec hugo d'accord
laetitia ce que voulaient voir cette
séquence où est-ce que de vous embête
non mais non gers il est ici entre à ce
que vous voulez vous êtes l'invité de
cette émission est 11ème et isla ces
partis regarder ces des rixes et l'a
gardée c'est juste là je met à côté de
vous parce que on sait jamais un malheur
est vite arrivé
[Musique]
ah ça chez oracle un plateau couscous
koh lanta en puces et la réunification
tu m'appelles pas non plus la tâche et
raccroche pour moi la paix compte de ta
race de téléphone si nos cd salut d'éric
saillour canon mais qu'est ce que tu as
mon mail des shows parc ramène toi mais
je n'ai rien à [ __ ] comme ici ok
j'arrive
alors tes deux ans elles sont où ces
gonzesses
elles sont juste là derrière toi et j'ai
comme l'impression qu'elles boivent de
l'alcool a aussi repéré des tours de toi
fais bellec avons oublié et qu'est ce
qu'on fait maintenant
bon à partir de maintenant c'est déry
qui prend les choses en main qui a
compris chauffe la technique c'est comme
ça que j'ai michele sur ce trou de avec
emma regarde les deux ringard qui
arrivent les beaux lots sera lé gaz et
qu'est ce que vous faites ou soeurs et
salut les filles
bon qu'est ce que vous voulez je peux
posément terme à 2 secondes
ok pour semer en plein régime et raj
peut pas laisser de bons appareils sans
surveillance bon moi c'est dirigé 29 ans
attentats ouais mais c'est parce que
derrick y fait moins que son âge
et toi timide comment tu t'appelles lui
s'appelle pas à les sauver c'est l'autre
bodart de bourgueil il sert à rien et
roulant baissé en plus il a une vraie
tête de corps c'est blessant mais c'est
drôle
rebelote d'eric c'est un coup de chance
et rien ça bien sûr c'est toujours moi
qui me fais avoir
je paye tous les sens la bouffe le resto
et à la fin qu'est ce qu'il ya pour
goergl rien du tout mais j'aurais pu les
pêcheurs pas du tout des rides c'était
joué d'avancé pour toi et en plus tu les
as tiennent chez moi et chez ma femme à
la kasbah nous sommes le soir la coupe
est pleine
j'en ai plus que marre de faire ce qui
na in utile d'insister bering c'est fini
entre nous j'ai tourné la page et
coutumes à bouaflé toutes les choses en
toute fin de façon sauf les bananes
thonon 2
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]